la carrera para liderar el reino unido y
hasta en marcha aunque para algunos ya
ha terminado
existe una 88 350 30 37 zahawi 25 de
asisa con soja wii francifol
por lo tanto según las reglas que
acordamos para esta votación dos
candidatos serán eliminados jeremy hunt
y eddie zahawi web y el isr los intentos
del ex secretario de salud germán así
como de eddie zahawi para convertirse en
el nuevo primer ministro del país
terminaron pronto mientras que
richardson act y penny morton van a la
delantera listos gaming band the knack
champ tugendhat y estela bravo berman
completan la lista de los seis
candidatos restantes ya que el jueves se
celebrará una segunda ronda de
votaciones en los próximos días los que
tengan menos votos serán descartados
antes del gran enfrentamiento en el que
los 160.000 miembros del partido
conservador decidirán quién en los
últimos candidatos quieren que dedica el
país
al igual que cualquiera de ellos
limpiaría el suelo con el capitán raúl y
snoods ex señor presidente y después de
unas semanas eso es exactamente lo que
harán se unirán en torno al ganador y
harán precisamente eso
en el presidente me iré pronto con la
cabeza en alto estas son las palabras de
boris johnson dirigidas al líder de la
oposición mientras pasa sus últimas
semanas en el cargo antes de su salida
prevista para el mes de septiembre
quieres tomar el líder laborista
respondió diciendo que johnson era
totalmente iluso y que echaría de menos
sus tonterías semanales durante el turno
de preguntas al primer ministro